i'm madison mills this is bloomberg
quick take the cost of food energy and
housing surged in november as americans
endure the highest annual inflation
since 1982. for u.s consumers prices
jumped nearly 7 in november from a year
ago as inflation intensifies pressure on
lower income households and especially
for those everyday necessities ahead of
the holiday season
so how will this affect wages and those
christmas gift lists and the big ticket
purchases that you may have been
planning to make all year
we want to welcome back marcia mantell
from mantel investments she is our
personal finance guru
marsha inflation has been a constant
theme this past year and the latest
numbers are certainly eye-popping but i
wonder how much of it is because we're
kind of less attentive to the true price
of goods there are some economists who
say that consumers are mainly shocked by
rising inflation because we had such a
long period of low inflation before the
pandemic so my question to you is do you
think americans have become too
comfortable with just expecting prices
to hold at current levels
i do i absolutely agree with that
comment and and it's easy to get lulled
into that
scarlett and maddie because it hasn't
been like it's been a year or two that
we've had this
managed inflation at around one and a
half to two and a half percent
it's been since the 80s since since i
graduated from high school and college
in 1983
we've had this very steady you know
little bumps here and there but
generally steady
slow increase in prices and our wages
have generally been able to keep up
but all of a sudden we're getting some
pretty snazzy headlines today that this
is you know very dramatic to have a 6.8
increase in all items from last november
to this november so that's quite
substantial it's not two percent
but it's also not as dramatic as it
seems on the surface it may not be as
dramatic for everyone but for me it
feels like the most
intense financial downfall of my
lifetime not to be you know overdramatic
or anything um you know i'm i'm my
family's from tampa they have the
highest inflation rate in the country
i'm gonna be there for the holidays in a
few weeks um what's next in terms of
when i can expect this to level off or
is this just how it's going to be from
now on
no you know maddie i i appreciate your
comments and as you know i have
girls your age as well and and it is a
little shocking you know things that you
bought
six months ago are now
are noticeably higher or for the same
hundred dollars you cannot fill that
grocery bag with as much stuff as you
used to
so this is a real thing especially when
food gets involved you know the big
indicators and the big inflation busters
right now are housing rent vehicles well
if you're not buying a new house if
you're not buying getting a new
apartment and seeing rent increases and
if you're not buying a new car that
wouldn't really matter
but food and gas
and fuel oil for the the folks of us who
those of us who live in the north
you feel it you see it in your
pocketbook you see that your dollar
doesn't stretch so far
but i want to give you a little
perspective because i mentioned in the
in the early 80s late 70s early 80s
there was a four year run of extreme
what i would call extreme inflation i'm
talking double digits every single month
the year-over-year numbers moved up 13
14 17. and it went on for four years
this doesn't feel the same for us older
timers uh it really doesn't that was a
particular era where we had all kinds of
situations that
that made for inflationary high
inflationary situations what we have
today is this real rub and i know you
guys talk about this all the time the
supply and demand you know our supply is
a lot less when our demand is a lot
higher
and that you know this is where all
boats rise
and in this case it's with inflation so
what to expect
you know there's still going to be some
some bouncing around of cost
inflation overall and pretty much the
only direction costs go are up
but what we'd like to see is a little
steadier you know
0.2 percent per month or a half a
percent per month
and and that's where i think two things
maddie one is that
there will still be
increases that you're going to feel real
consumers are really going to feel these
prices for a while yet but i encourage
you to look underneath the big headline
number
it isn't 6.8 for everything yeah and
you know i talk about ice cream you know
that's one of my favorite foods and
that's one of the items i track i am
happy to report ice cream has not gone
up nearly that high oh thank god
what you're gonna do is look for look
for good news within the harder to take
news i'm gonna adjust accordingly i'm
gonna eat less beef and go with ice
cream which i've always wanted to do
anyway but here's your reason exactly
marcia i mean there will be a lot of
finger pointing at the central bank and
at the white house and we know when we
had this period of rapid inflation in
the late 70s and early 80s the
prescription is to raise interest rates
and that's exactly what paul volcker did
at the federal reserve to the chagrin of
so many people because it was it was a
hard adjustment from where you sit is
that the most effective way policy
makers and elected officials can fight
inflation or is there another way to
slow down the price increase
that is a great question you know i
don't have that
great policy phd background in economics
so i'm going to let the economist speak
to that but what i will say is when
prices start to move higher we also need
to see things like wages increasing and
the interest rates for our savings
accounts to also increase so that we
don't see such a huge disparity between
high costs and purchasing power so
rising interest rates i listened to a
few articles this morning and read a few
things you know that's already on the
table
um
it's going to be interesting to watch
over the next few months and it's hard
when inflation has this high a jump at
the holiday time you know we're already
buying a lot more than maybe we normally
do i think we just all need to take a
little bit of a breath wait until
february and march let's see where the
supply gets bigger demand settles in
that's not holiday
and see where our numbers end up
absolutely and maddie that would be good
news for people who have been saving
money and don't collect a lot of
interest for it if interest rates do
start to increase that's true and that
was one of my big questions for you
marcia for the folks who uh are
getting closer to retirement i mean how
concerned should they be and is there
any way to kind of gain inflation to
your benefit
oh isn't that a good question
the best way to
kind of bend inflation and make sure
that it works for you is to make sure
you have a really good investment
strategy that has a significant
component for growth
so again all of these factors have to
balance each other out and the more you
know that or see that and make sure your
investments are aligned to we always
talk about it in the industry is you
want to have investments that beat
inflation or hedge inflation
well we're living it now it's no longer
a concept you know so we really need to
make sure that we don't get nervous and
you know sell
and and make big bold moves and pendulum
swing when that is not a strategy that's
a reaction so make sure your strategy is
really tight and in place if you have a
financial advisor talk to that financial
advisor make sure you understand what's
going on because frankly the market is
up it's gangbusters right but now we
have some higher inflation so it's
offsetting purchasing power and future
purchasing power so i i think we all
just need to get a little more connected
to how the markets move and when one of
the
the pistons you know moves a little
faster than it usually does yeah
absolutely marcia for a country of
savers uh inflation is bad news
because it devalues what you have there
unless of course you can make up for it
with rising investments but for a
country with a lot of debt rising
inflation is good because it also
devalues the debt
my question too is does that same kind
of thinking apply to individuals and
households like if you have a lot of
consumer debt if you have a lot of
credit card debt or student debt is
inflation good news for you
well i think overall when you have
consumer debt not mortgage mortgage is
kind of its own category
it is very tough if you're not keeping
up with your credit card payments i mean
the interest rates already are so very
high
and where
where i look at it from that consumer
you know literally you know mom and pop
sitting down to pay bills
when inflation is rising and they have
to pay more at the grocery store they
have less less to pay that credit card
outstanding balance and because the
rates on credit cards for example are so
high
you end up you know having to elongate
and stretch out your payments therefore
paying more
so
it's more important to have a good debt
approach you know if you can don't get
yourself over your skis here with debt
but if you have really work hard to chip
away at that debt high interest rates
not so good having to spend money now at
the grocery store instead of paying down
debt not so good yeah
really quickly in our final 30 seconds
here what's your number one biggest tip
for dealing with inflation
budget
get reacquainted with your budget ladies
it is really looking hard at where
you're spending and where can you make
some trade-offs as we go through this
bumpy juncture here right right if
anything maybe i can convince myself
it's an opportunity to get reacquainted
with budgeting again marcia always
appreciate speaking with you thank you
so much for joining us today that was
marcia mantel from mantel investments